[Music]
lighting is something which is pretty
static you think about it when it
doesn't work anymore the change we led
is that gentleman became greener and
more sustainable but it became
intelligent Phillips hue is an
internet-connected lighting solution you
can steer your lighting with your voice
have lights change with music when you
have a party as well as an element of
comfort and security in it when we
launched Philips you we didn't know
where ever we needed infrastructure for
a thousand people or a million people we
want to do just to scale and work so our
choice of partners was fundamental we
needed that scalability that back-end
that robustness that maturity that's why
you selected Google we've worked with
the Google cloud team since the very
beginning at the moment we're running on
the Google container engine this is
working fantastically for us by breaking
our application down into containers we
have all these small parts that we can
deploy release test independently and
that's allow us to move too much faster
release cycles we were able to spend
less time think we move infrastructure
and more time focusing on the
applications and the use cases for
consumer we are really getting close to
the cutting edge of what's there we are
growing tremendously and we want to make
sure that we can deliver the lighting
experience we want in every single home
[Music]